[Musica]
non so voi ma io non avrei mai pensato
che la didattica c'entrasse in qualche
modo con il coraggio e invece
ultimamente da un anno mi sto
profondamente convincendo che sia vero
esattamente il contrario e cioè che solo
con un coraggio riusciamo davvero a
introdurre innovazione all'interno del
mondo dell'insegnamento
ebbene sì parliamo di dat
no questo acronimo che dall essere più o
meno sconosciuto nel giro di un anno è
diventato uno dei più popolari tanto da
essere inserito dall accademia della
crusca tra i neologismi del 2020
e interessante nel giro di poche
settimane
molti istituti di educazione le
università molte scuole sono passati da
al cento per cento in presenza al cento
per cento a distanza
molto interessante
interessante collocare questo caso
all'interno di un discorso più ampio che
è studiato da tanto tempo da almeno un
secolo
un fenomeno che si chiama il fenomeno
del cambiamento accelerato cioè un
fenomeno per il quale l'innovazione
tecnologica procede ad una velocità che
è particolarmente elevata e
progressivamente crescente è una cosa
appunto che dicevo si studi da tanto
tempo e la sua peculiarità non sta tanto
nella velocità o nell'accelerazione
della innovazione tecnologica ma nella
disallineamento tra l'innovazione
tecnologica ei cambiamenti di tipo
sociale e culturale sembra un concetto
estremamente astratto allora io ho
pensato potesse essere utile
sperimentare direttamente questo
disallineamento questa a sincronia
andando a recuperare ad esempio in cui
la sincronia è più facile da intuire e
fare un esperimento insieme a voi
prendiamo un compositore classico noto a
tutti e prendiamo un suo brano
particolarmente noto la sonata al chiaro
di luna al piano naturalmente e
ascoltiamo un piccolo pezzo
[Musica]
stupendo brano stupenda melodia melodia
che si compone dal come risultato delle
azioni e delle esecuzioni due mani nella
mano destra e la sinistra che si devono
muovere secondo le specifiche
indicate dal compositore ad una certa
velocità ad un certo tempo ecco lo
vediamo qua è un adagio sostenuto cosa
succede se però isoliamo la mano
sinistra in questo adagio
[Musica]
e veramente molto lento quasi sembrano
più pause che non note musicali
ma a questo punto proviamo a giocare un
po e vediamo che succederebbe se
improvvisamente la mano destra decidesse
di accelerare in suonasse un allegretto
sempre le stesse note
[Musica]
inevitabile a questo punto completare
gioco vediamo cosa succede e mettendo
insieme le due parti le due mani alle
due velocità diverse
ok
il cambiamento accelerato funziona
esattamente in questo modo la mano
destra la tecnologia
procede improvvisamente con una velocità
maggiore questo succede quando si
introduce una tecnologia in
un'organizzazione
mentre la mano sinistra continua
imperterrita nel suo adagio la mano
sinistra sono le persone che operano in
organizzazione questo fenomeno e come
dicevo vale per tante tecnologie nelle
tecnologie digitali è il risultato
particolarmente evidente è ancora più
evidente quando si è trattato di avere a
che fare con il covip
verrebbe da dire a e meno male che
c'erano le tecnologie meno male cioè che
nel 2020 non avevamo i cosiddetti
cervelloni elettronici un termine che
credo che alle nuove generazioni non
dica proprio niente invece è stato il
fondamento di tante conversazioni del
per le persone della mia età ha
fortunatamente c'era questa tecnologia
ma è
lavorare su questa tecnologia introdurre
questa tecnologia ha richiesto forse
coraggio siamo stati bravi sicuramente a
reagire velocemente alla pandemia
impedendo che ci fosse uno stop completo
della didattica
ma che fatica abbiamo fatto si è
trattato soprattutto di un problema di
budget diciamocelo è bastato investire
acquisire la tecnologia laddove
possibile naturalmente e metterla a
disposizione la mano destra accelerato
tantissimo non 1 allegretto direi un
presto un prestissimo e la mano sinistra
ma non è che le cose siano andate
benissimo perché se sono veri meme che
circolano da un po di tempo online nei
social
alcune cose non sono andate proprio
esattamente come dovevano
la fatica di seguire lezioni infinite il
carico didattico dei docenti e degli
studenti
la incapacità di apprendere secondo
modelli nuovi
ha creato più di qualche problema
e se andiamo quindi possiamo dire se la
mano sinistra sostanzialmente in molti
casi è rimasta indietro è rimasto a
suonare il suo adagio ma allarghiamo la
nostra prospettiva e consideriamo il
pianista
chi decide le strategie e le metodologie
delle università cos'ha fatto nel
frattempo
quanto è riuscito a generare delle nuove
idee dal delle nuove prospettive per i
prossimi semestri che ci aspettano ecco
ci sono due filoni di pensiero molto
diversi diciamo uno che è
verso una restaurazione ritorniamo prima
possibile in tutte le aule
l'altro aumentiamo la digitalizzazione
della nostra università
ecco qui mi devo fermare perché la
parola digitalizzazione penso sia
veramente una parola che crea confusione
anziché chiarire gli obiettivi
digitalizzare evoca smartphone ap realtà
virtuale intelligenza artificiale cioè
tecnologia la mano destra e anche
trasformazione digitale ancora fa
pensare al fatto che ciò che si deve
trasformare sia il digital la tecnologia
ma se invece noi abbiamo bisogno di far
lavorare meglio in modo diverso sia la
mano destra che la sinistra
e se è il pianista che deve coordinare
tutto questo allora forse abbiamo
bisogno di trasformazione più importante
da capo a piedi alle mani intendo
naturalmente
e allora forse non si chiama
trasformazione ma è una metamorfosi ecco
a me piace e convitti e stein lavorare
sul lessico quando ci sono dei messaggi
importanti da dare perché scriveva le
parole formano danno forma alla realtà
che conosciamo e parlare di metamorfosi
digitale secondo me è molto più preciso
rispetto a i termini che abbiamo usato
prima quindi io sono convinto della
necessità di una metamorfosi digitale
delle università
in che cosa può consistere
ma pensiamo davvero che possa consistere
unicamente nel
consegnare dei tablet ai nostri studenti
o installare delle lavagne interattive
multimediali in tutte le nostre aule di
nuovo significa lavorare come al solito
nella parte della mano destra significa
fare investimenti non significa appunto
fare delle dei cambiamenti radicali non
è una metamorfosi
[Musica]
naturalmente questi strumenti sono molto
attraenti sembrano magici in poche
settimane ci hanno permesso di fare la
dad per tanti mesi bellissimo
mentre al contrario la metamorfosi è
molto incerta sapete quasi il 100 per
cento del corpo di un bruco svanisce per
dare la possibilità a papa alla farfalla
di uscire dal suo bozzolo e non è così
piacevole ma allora per sdrammatizzare
un attimo e anche per ricondurli alla
metafora iniziale
penso che possiamo
provare a pensare a come potremmo
evitare di finire in quella che non era
una sinfonia della sonata al chiaro di
luna che vi obbligati ascoltare la più
una cacofonia
però per farlo c'è bisogno di una
metamorfosi dobbiamo cambiare genere
musicale
ok spero che ludwig non si rivolti nella
tomba
se lo metto in parallelo ad eminem però
eminem è un personaggio interessante per
il mio racconto perché in particolare ha
scritto dei brani in particolare c'è uno
molto famoso che si chiama red dod in
cui usa una tecnica che si chiama extra
bit la faccio breve in pratica la voce
che corrisponde alla mano destra del
nostro della nostra metafora a un certo
punto del brano accelera ma non esce
dalla sincronia con la base rimane in
sincrono rispetto ai vincoli m c è
quindi il risultato è ragionato faccio
prima farmelo ascoltare
grazie
[Musica]
non mi son mai
questa è la parte iniziale del varano
dopo di che a un certo punto e per 31
secondi non ve le faccio ascoltare tutti
si va in extrability lescano in dieci
questo quest'area l'ex pg il turista ma
non abbiamo nome di passiamo da avellino
buona gara più degli elettori di non
saper di vendere bene per avere quando
sto bene mitiche sensi che s'è
capito che può piacere o non piacere a
voi però ci sono 730 milioni di
esecuzioni su spotify di questo brano
quindi un po famoso lo è forse non come
la sonata di beethoven
capite che
in questo modo
emine riesce a realizzare quello che
poteva sembrare impossibile e cioè a
unire a unire l'accelerazione della voce
ad una base musicale
ecco ripropongo quindi la mia proposta è
la mia domanda è l'università è in grado
di cambiare musica è in grado di fare
una metamorfosi
digitale
è in grado di
far sì che il bruco progressivamente
certo si trasformi in una farfalla è in
grado di superare l'incertezza e i
rischi che questo comporta
credo che non abbiamo scelta dobbiamo
avere coraggio qui sì c'è da avere
coraggio
per cambiare pelle per modificare le
logiche e le strategie a livello di chi
decide in alto e per modificare il
proprio modo di insegnare e il proprio
modo di imparare per me e per i miei
studenti
bisogna avere coraggio si fa fatica
per fortuna però ci possiamo far aiutare
c'è la disciplina si chiama pedagogia e
che è proprio dovrebbe essere messa al
centro di questo processo di metamorfosi
digitale non è una cosa così strana in
fondo
l'università non so se lo sapete ha tre
obiettivi principali vengono chiamati in
missioni la prima la seconda e la terza
missione
indovinate qual è la prima non la
ricerca come pensano tanti accademici e
la didattica
e 61 apre un libro qualunque di storia
della pedagogia nel primo capitolo
troverà quasi certamente
questa immagine
la scuola di atene
o meglio un modello pedagogico la
paideia che risale al quinto secolo
avanti cristo non dobbiamo inventare
tutto da zero ha tra l'altro questo
modello è stato realizzato implementato
da platone in una scuola che guarda caso
si chiamava accademia interessante forse
ce lo siamo un pò dimenticato noi
accademici
bene
cosa immagine immagino che si possa
prendere questo modello e si possa
sfruttare se ne possano sfruttare i
principi che erano la formazione
continua l'interdisciplinarietà e il
ruolo sociale e politico dell'educazione
interessante
significa utilizzare questi principi
superare i pregiudizi pro e contro la
tecnologia
significa non ritornare all'adagio
sostenuto di entrambe le mani buttando
via quello che abbiamo imparato
dell'utilizzo delle tecnologie digitali
nell'ultimo anno
ma significa anche non
abbandonarsi all'entusiasmo e andare non
in extra bit ma in una appunto
dissonanza totale tra tecnologia docenti
e discenti io penso che si possa fare si
tratta naturalmente di studiare e
eventualmente se c'è bisogno di
inventare nuove strategie nuovi modelli
didattici
quando noi innanzitutto noi docenti
cominceremo a lavorare in questa
direzione
a mio avviso saremo in grado di fare di
realizzare questa metamorfosi digitale e
quindi a realizzare una nuova sinfonia
grazie
[Musica]